This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Over its more than 40-year journey from conception to completion, Boston's Big Dig massive infrastructure project, which rerouted the central highway in the heart of the city, encountered every hurdle imaginable, ruthless politics, engineering challenges, secretive contractors, outright fraud, and even the death of one motorist. It became kind of a poster child for big government boondoggles. But the full story, of course, is much more complicated, and really represents a turning
This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Over its more than 40-year journey from conception to completion, Boston's Big Dig massive infrastructure project, which rerouted the central highway in the heart of the city, encountered every hurdle imaginable, ruthless politics, engineering challenges, secretive contractors, outright fraud, and even the death of one motorist. It became kind of a poster child for big government boondoggles. But the full story, of course, is much more complicated, and really represents a turning |||这是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。在其从构思到完成历时40多年的过程中，波士顿的“中央干线地下化”工程——这个旨在重新规划市中心核心高速公路的大型基础设施项目，遇到了你能想象到的每一个障碍：残酷的政治、工程挑战、秘密承包商、彻头彻尾的欺诈，甚至还发生了一名司机死亡的悲剧。它几乎成了大政府愚蠢项目的典型代名词。但完整的故事当然要复杂得多，它实际上代表了一个转折点。
point in how America builds infrastructure. For much of the 20th century, public works projects were viewed as an unalloyed good. Our capacity to build big things was a point of American pride and something that both political parties could agree on. But as we learn more about the neighborhoods ruined, the lives affected, the graph taken, the cost overruns, and the environmental damage, all of which were being discussed more widely during an ascending movement towards privatization and small government, well, we got much more cynical, and public works became just like everything else.
point in how America builds infrastructure. For much of the 20th century, public works projects were viewed as an unalloyed good. Our capacity to build big things was a point of American pride and something that both political parties could agree on. But as we learn more about the neighborhoods ruined, the lives affected, the graph taken, the cost overruns, and the environmental damage, all of which were being discussion more widely during an ascending movement towards privatization and small government, well, we got much more cynical, and public works became just like everything else. |||即美国建造基础设施方式的改变。在20世纪的大部分时间里，公共工程项目被视为纯粹的好事。我们建造宏伟工程的能力曾是美国人的骄傲，也是两党能够达成共识的事情。但随着我们对被毁坏的社区、受影响的生活、被征用的土地、超支的成本以及环境破坏了解得越来越多——在转向私有化和小政府的上升运动中，所有这些都受到了更广泛的讨论——好吧，我们变得更加愤世嫉俗了，公共工程也变得和其它所有事情一样。
If you've ever had this question that I've had, can America still build big things? The story of the big dig in Boston has many of the answers, a project that had a raft of very public problems, but ultimately delivered on its promises. Today, we're presenting the first episode in a series that offers a true inside account of one of the most complicated and expensive public works projects in American history.
If you've ever had this question that I've had, can America still build big things? The story of the big dig in Boston has many of the answers, a project that had a raft of very public problems, but ultimately delivered on its promises. Today, we're presenting the first episode in a series that offers a true inside account of one of the most complicated and expensive public works projects in American history. |||如果你也曾有过我这样的疑问：美国还能建造宏伟的工程吗？波士顿“中央干线地下化”工程的故事包含了许多答案。这是一个曾有大量公开问题、但最终兑现了诺言的项目。今天，我们将推出该系列的第一集，为您真实揭秘美国历史上最复杂、最昂贵的公共工程项目之一的幕后内幕。
It is a remarkable rollercoaster ride of a documentary produced by WGBH in Boston and reported and hosted by Ian Koss. Enjoy. There are many strange and bitter ironies in the story of the big dig, but here's what has to be my favorite. It's the most expensive highway project ever built in America, and yet the architect, the man who started it all hated highways. My grandmother lived near here on Lincoln Street. A man named Fred Salvucci.
It is a remarkable rollercoaster ride of a documentary produced by WGBH in Boston and reported and hosted by Ian Koss. Enjoy. There are many strange and bitter ironies in the story of the big dig, but here's what has to be my favorite. It's the most expensive highway project ever built in America, and yet the architect, the man who started it all hated highways. My grandmother lived near here on Lincoln Street. A man named Fred Salvucci. |||这是一部由波士顿WGBH制作、伊恩·科斯（Ian Koss）报道和主持的精彩绝伦、跌宕起伏的纪录片。请欣赏。“中央干线地下化”的故事中有许多奇怪而痛苦的讽刺，但以下绝对是我最喜欢的一个。这是美国历史上建造的最昂贵的高速公路项目，然而它的建筑师、这一切的始作俑者却讨厌高速公路。我外祖母以前就住在林肯街附近。一个名叫弗雷德·萨尔武奇的人。
And I had to engage in ethnic stereotypes. She was this Italian lady that grew terrific tomatoes and sold them to the Polish people next door, as if only Italians know how to grow tomatoes. But she grew everything there. Tomatoes, potatoes, beans, basil, garlic. It was an incredibly big garden. And she lost all that. Yeah, she lost all that. The Massachusetts turnfights stretches across the state like a life-giving artery, 123 miles. Back in the 1950s, when Fred Salvucci was a teenager, the state of Massachusetts was on a highway building
And I had to engage in ethnic stereotypes. She was this Italian lady that grew terrific tomatoes and sold them to the Polish people next door, as if only Italians know how to grow tomatoes. But she grew everything there. Tomatoes, potatoes, beans, basil, garlic. It was an incredibly big garden. And she lost all that. Yeah, she lost all that. The Massachusetts turnfights stretches across the state like a life-giving artery, 123 miles. Back in the 1950s, when Fred Salvucci was a teenager, the state of Massachusetts was on a highway building |||我不得不使用一些族裔刻板印象。她是一位意大利老太太，种出了极棒的西红柿，并把它们卖给隔壁的波兰人，就好像只有意大利人才懂得种西红柿似的。但她什么都在那里种。西红柿、土豆、豆类、罗勒、大蒜。那是一个大得惊人的花园。而她失去了这一切。是的，她失去了这一切。马萨诸塞州收费公路横贯全州，像一条给予生命的动脉，长达123英里。早在20世纪50年代，当弗雷德·萨尔武奇还是个青少年时，马萨诸塞州正处于高速公路建设的狂潮中。
spree, east to west, north to south, and all around the city of Boston. The greatest of these new roads was the mass turnpike. Six lanes, three in each direction, a highway miracle, niping through the heart of New England. The state celebrated the occasion with this nearly hour long documentary film. But for a young Savuji, it was not a time to celebrate, because the road came right through his neighborhood. They took the southern half of Lincoln Street. The neighborhood was mostly Lithuanian and Polish people.
spree, east to west, north to south, and all around the city of Boston. The greatest of these new roads was the mass turnpike. Six lanes, three in each direction, a highway miracle, niping through the heart of New England. The state celebrated the occasion with this nearly hour long documentary film. But for a young Savuji, it was not a time to celebrate, because the road came right through his neighborhood. They took the southern half of Lincoln Street. The neighborhood was mostly Lithuanian and Polish people. |||从东到西，从南到北，遍布波士顿市周围。这些新道路中最宏伟的就是马萨诸塞州收费公路。六车道，双向各三车道，这是一个高速公路奇迹，呼啸着穿过新英格兰的核心地带。州政府用这部将近一小时长的纪录片来庆祝这一时刻。但对年轻的萨尔武奇来说，这不是一个值得庆祝的时刻，因为这条路正好穿过了他的社区。他们占领了林肯街的南部。这个社区住的主要是立陶宛人和波兰人。
Very poor people with no education didn't know how to protect themselves. Obviously some families had to be moved. Structures not worth saving were demolished or burned on the spot. My grandmother was a 70 year old widow. They came to her house in September and gave her a dollar and a piece of paper saying, the land is now ours, you have to go, will eventually
Very poor people with no education didn't know how to protect themselves. Obviously some families had to be moved. Structures not worth saving were demolished or burned on the spot. My grandmother was a 70 year old widow. They came to her house in September and gave her a dollar and a piece of paper saying, the land is now ours, you have to go, will eventually |||非常贫穷且没有受过教育的人，不知道如何保护自己。显然，有些家庭必须搬迁。不值得保留的建筑被当场拆除或烧毁。我外祖母当时是一名70岁的寡妇。他们在9月份来到她家，给了她一美元和一张纸，上面写着：这块土地现在是我们的了，你必须离开，我们最终会
give you an estimate of what we're willing to pay. And they just squeezed people. And to those responsible for the turnpikes building, we say hats off. So it was outrageous and I kind of promised myself that if I ever had anything to do with public works, I would never treat people the way people had treated my grandmother with the turnpike. So why is it that a man scarred by highways would set out to build one? The answer is that he wanted to build a better kind of highway, a more humane kind of highway, and that's what the big dig was.
give you an estimate of what we're willing to pay. And they just squeezed people. And to those responsible for the turnpikes building, we say hats off. So it was outrageous and I kind of promised myself that if I ever had anything to do with public works, I would never treat people the way people had treated my grandmother with the turnpike. So why is it that a man scarred by highways would set out to build one? The answer is that he wanted to build a better kind of highway, a more humane kind of highway, and that's what the big dig was. |||给你我们愿意支付的估价。他们就这样压榨人们。而对于那些对收费公路建设负有责任的人，我们只能脱帽致敬。所以这太离谱了，我暗暗对自己发誓，如果我以后有机会参与公共工程，我绝不会像当年收费公路那样对待我外祖母。那么，为什么一个饱受高速公路创伤的人会着手建造一条高速公路呢？答案是，他想建造一种更好、更有人情味的高速公路，这就是“中央干线地下化”工程的意义所在。
But if that's all it was, well, we wouldn't be here. Would we? The subject of infrastructure inspires deep cynicism in America today. There's a feeling that once our cities were the envy of the world, but now we can barely keep our trains running. That once we built the interstate, and now, anytime we even attempt something ambitious, it's over budget and behind schedule before a single shovel hits the dirt. Running nearly three years behind schedule, the lake could jeopardize the train's funding plan and...
But if that's all it was, well, we wouldn't be here. Would we? The subject of infrastructure inspires deep cynicism in America today. There's a feeling that once our cities were the envy of the world, but now we can barely keep our trains running. That once we built the interstate, and now, anytime we even attempt something ambitious, it's over budget and behind schedule before a single shovel hits the dirt. Running nearly three years behind schedule, the lake could jeopardize the train's funding plan and... |||但如果仅仅如此，好吧，我们就不会坐在这里了。不是吗？今天，基础设施这个话题在美国引发了深深的愤世嫉俗情绪。人们有一种感觉：曾几何时，我们的城市是全世界羡慕的对象，但现在我们几乎连火车都快开不稳了；曾几何时，我们修建了洲际公路，而现在，每当我们尝试任何雄心勃勃的项目时，往往在第一把铁锹动土之前就已经超预算且延期了。落后计划近三年，这个湖泊可能会危及列车的资金计划，而且……
There's almost a sense of glee. Each time our doubts are proven correct. A multi-billion dollar project now we can shake our heads and laugh it off. What a joke. But only after many more years of costly and complicated construction. For me, no one project embodies the cynicism around American infrastructure. Quite like the one Fred Savucci would one day take on. What we hear in Boston call the Big Dig.
There's almost a sense of glee. Each time our doubts are proven correct. A multi-billion dollar project now we can shake our heads and laugh it off. What a joke. But only after many more years of costly and complicated construction. For me, no one project embodies the cynicism around American infrastructure. Quite like the one Fred Savucci would one day take on. What we hear in Boston call the Big Dig. |||每当我们的怀疑被证实是正确的时候，几乎甚至有一种幸灾乐祸的感觉。一个价值数十亿美元的项目，现在我们只能摇摇头一笑置之。真是个笑话。但这只是在经历了多年昂贵且复杂的建设之后。对我而言，没有哪个项目能像弗雷德·萨尔武奇日后接手的那个项目那样，如此体现出围绕美国基础设施的愤世嫉俗。我们在波士顿称之为“中央干线地下化”。
If you think you are furious about the Big Dig, the mess, and the cost overruns, you've got company. If that name Big Dig has only the vaguest meaning to you, don't sweat it. We'll get there. But it was a tunnel project. And when I was going up in Massachusetts in the 1990s, it was hard to ignore. Back then, the project went by many names. It was called the Big Mess, the Big Hole, the Big Pig, the Big Lie. It was, as everyone loved to point out, the most expensive public works project in American history, full stop. It went on in my young mind forever, from before I started kindergarten until after I graduated high school. And at the end of all that, it was held up for the world to see as a boondoggle.
If you think you are furious about the Big Dig, the mess, and the cost overruns, you've got company. If that name Big Dig has only the vaguest meaning to you, don't sweat it. We'll get there. But it was a tunnel project. And when I was going up in Massachusetts in the 1990s, it was hard to ignore. Back then, the project went by many names. It was called the Big Mess, the Big Hole, the Big Pig, the Big Lie. It was, as everyone loved to point out, the most expensive public works project in American history, full stop. It went on in my young mind forever, from before I started kindergarten until after I graduated high school. And at the end of all that, it was held up for the world to see as a boondoggle. |||如果你对“中央干线地下化”、那一团糟的状况以及成本超支感到愤怒，并不只有你一个人。如果“中央干线地下化”这个名字对你来说只有最模糊的意义，别担心。我们后面会讲到。但那是一个隧道项目。当我在20世纪90年代在马萨诸塞州长大时，这个项目是很难忽视的。当时，这个项目有很多名字。它被称为“大混乱”、“大深坑”、“大肥猪”、“大谎言”。正如每个人都喜欢指出的那样，它是美国历史上最昂贵的公共工程项目，句号。在我的童年记忆里，它似乎永远不会结束，从我上幼儿园之前一直持续到我高中毕业之后。而在这一切的最后，它被作为一项劳民伤财的失败工程公之于众，供全世界参观。
A $14 billion V-ASCO. A cautionary tale. Did everything that could go wrong. A punchline. The big dig, a construction project that backed up traffic for 16 years. I mean, there are computers just getting home now. But if it is a joke, then the joke's on us. And I don't just mean us, the suckers up in Boston. I mean all of us. Because there are big things that need building in this country.
A $14 billion V-ASCO. A cautionary tale. Did everything that could go wrong. A punchline. The big dig, a construction project that backed up traffic for 16 years. I mean, there are computers just getting home now. But if it is a joke, then the joke's on us. And I don't just mean us, the suckers up in Boston. I mean all of us. Because there are big things that need building in this country. |||一个耗资14亿美元的巨大惨败。一个前车之鉴。所有可能出错的地方都出错了。一个笑柄。“中央干线地下化”，一个导致交通拥堵长达16年的建设工程。我的意思是，有些电脑现在才刚把车开回家。但如果这是一个笑话，那么这个笑话就是在嘲弄我们自己。我指的不只是我们这些在波士顿当冤大头的人。我是指我们所有人。因为这个国家有许多宏伟的工程需要建设。
And I, for one, want to know where that cynicism comes from, the feeling that America can't build big things. My name is Ian Koss and from GPH News, this is The Big Dig, a study in American infrastructure. In many ways, this first episode is the prequel, the turning point that sets the whole saga in motion. We're not going to talk about the big dig just yet, or about how hard it is to build in America. We're going to start back in a time when America built a lot, maybe too much, especially when it came to highways. This is the story of the inevitable backlash, the anti-pioe movement. Part 1. We Were Wrong.
And I, for one, want to know where that cynicism comes from, the feeling that America can't build big things. My name is Ian Koss and from GPH News, this is The Big Dig, a study in American infrastructure. In many ways, this first episode is the prequel, the turning point that sets the whole saga in motion. We're not going to talk about the big dig just yet, or about how hard it is to build in America. We're going to start back in a time when America built a lot, maybe too much, especially when it came to highways. This is the story of the inevitable backlash, the anti-pioe movement. Part 1. We Were Wrong. |||而我，作为其中一员，想知道这种愤世嫉俗的情绪从何而来——那种认为美国无法建造宏伟工程的感觉。我叫伊恩·科斯（Ian Koss），来自GPH新闻，这是《中央干线地下化：美国基础设施研究》。在许多方面，这第一集是前传，是拉开整个传奇序幕的转折点。我们现在还不打算讨论“中央干线地下化”，也不打算讨论在美国搞建设有多难。我们要从美国大兴土木的时代说起，也许当时建得太多了，特别是在修建高速公路方面。这就是关于不可避免的反弹、即反高速公路运动的故事。第一部分：我们错了。
The origin story of Fred Savucci and the Big Dig are really one in the same story. They both begin with the truly most sweeping and expensive building project in American history. That would be the interstate system. This is the American dream of freedom on wheels, an automotive age traveling on time-saving superhighways. The Interstate is so ubiquitous now. It's almost invisible to us. We're talking about nearly 50,000 miles of highway running through every state in the country. It's the reason you can drive from Seattle to Boston without making a single turn
The origin story of Fred Savucci and the Big Dig are really one in the same story. They both begin with the truly most sweeping and expensive building project in American history. That would be the interstate system. This is the American dream of freedom on wheels, an automotive age traveling on time-saving superhighways. The Interstate is so ubiquitous now. It's almost invisible to us. We're talking about nearly 50,000 miles of highway running through every state in the country. It's the reason you can drive from Seattle to Boston without making a single turn |||弗雷德·萨尔武奇的起源故事和“中央干线地下化”实际上是同一个故事。它们都始于美国历史上真正最宏大、最昂贵的建设项目。那便是州际公路系统。这就是车轮上的自由的美国梦，一个在省时的高速公路上行进的汽车时代。州际公路现在无处不在。对我们来说，它几乎是隐形的。我们谈论的是将近5万英里的公路，穿过全国每一个州。这就是为什么你可以从西雅图一路开到波士顿，而无需拐弯
or hitting a single traffic light, and not just to the edge of the city, but right into the heart of it. They can lift traffic up over city congestion with elevated highways raised by an aroused public. In the 50s and 60s, these roads meant progress, the future. The big American cities, including Boston, were losing people to the suburbs, specifically white people. Highways were seen as a way to bring them back in, and for the states, the whole thing was basically free. President Eisenhower's militant call for a modern controlled access highway system led to the passage of the Federal Aid Highway Act of 1956.
or hitting a single traffic light, and not just to the edge of the city, but right into the heart of it. They can lift traffic up over city congestion with elevated highways raised by an aroused public. In the 50s and 60s, these roads meant progress, the future. The big American cities, including Boston, were losing people to the suburbs, specifically white people. Highways were seen as a way to bring them back in, and for the states, the whole thing was basically free. President Eisenhower's militant call for a modern controlled access highway system led to the passage of the Federal Aid Highway Act of 1956. |||或遇到一个红绿灯，而且不仅能开到城市的边缘，还能直接开进市中心。他们可以通过激昂的公众修建的高架高速公路，将车流从城市的拥堵上方抬升过去。在50年代和60年代，这些道路意味着进步、未来。包括波士顿在内的美国大城市正在流失人口到郊区，尤其是白人。高速公路被视为将他们吸引回来的途径，对各州而言，整个项目基本上是免费的。艾森豪威尔总统对建立现代控制出入高速公路系统的强硬呼吁，促成了1956年《联邦援助公路法案》的通过。
The deal was this. The feds provide 90% of the money. The states are responsible for the planning and building. As long as what you're building is an interstate highway. In Massachusetts, just like everywhere else, the interstate program was a pretty hard deal to turn down. You had federal money available, ready to go, you had a plan, and the promise of jobs to the tune of about a billion dollars. So to say no to all that seemed unthinkable.
The deal was this. The feds provide 90% of the money. The states are responsible for the planning and building. As long as what you're building is an interstate highway. In Massachusetts, just like everywhere else, the interstate program was a pretty hard deal to turn down. You had federal money available, ready to go, you had a plan, and the promise of jobs to the tune of about a billion dollars. So to say no to all that seemed unthinkable. |||这笔交易是这样的：联邦政府提供90%的资金。各州负责规划和建设。只要你修建的是州际公路。在马萨诸塞州，和其他地方一样，州际公路计划是一项很难拒绝的交易。你有联邦资金支持，随时可以动工，你有一份计划，还有大约十亿美元的工作岗位承诺。因此，对这一切说“不”似乎是不可想象的。
Carolyn Crockett is the author of the book People Before Highways and also a professor at MIT. She argues that despite all the incentives to build, build, build, the costs of that building would eventually force city residents to think the unthinkable. So the anti-highway fight becomes a moment of imagining possibilities. In the 1960s, there were anti-highway movements all over the country. In San Francisco, New York, DC, in., in many ways Boston was late to the party, but the consequences of what happened here would be more sweeping than any of the highway battles before it. It would change the way cities and states around the country thought about their
Carolyn Crockett is the author of the book People Before Highways and also a professor at MIT. She argues that despite all the incentives to build, build, build, the costs of that building would eventually force city residents to think the unthinkable. So the anti-highway fight becomes a moment of imagining possibilities. In the 1960s, there were anti-highway movements all over the country. In San Francisco, New York, DC, in., in many ways Boston was late to the party, but the consequences of what happened here would be more sweeping than any of the highway battles before it. It would change the way cities and states around the country thought about their |||卡罗琳·克罗克特（Carolyn Crockett）是《道路之上的居民》（People Before Highways）一书的作者，也是麻省理工学院的教授。她认为，尽管有所有鼓励“大兴土木”的激励措施，但建设的代价最终将迫使城市居民去思考那些不可想象的事情。因此，反高速公路斗争成了一个设想各种可能性的时刻。在20世纪60年代，全美各地都爆发了反高速公路运动。在旧金山、纽约、华盛顿特区……在许多方面，波士顿算是后知后觉，但这里发生的事情所产生的后果，将比以往任何一场高速公路之战都要深远。它将改变全国各地的城市和州对
urban highways. And Fred Salvucci was at the center of it. So to go back to where we started, with young Fred Salvucci's story, when he made that promise to his grandmother to treat people better, to build more humanely, it was not at all clear he would ever get to act on it. As long as he could remember, the plan had always been for him to be a bricklayer, like his father, Guido, was. G. Salvucci and company would become G. Salvucci and son. The plan got thrown off when Fred was in junior high. His music teacher saw potential in him, and suggested he apply for the city's most prestigious public school, Boston Latin, and he got in.
urban highways. And Fred Salvucci was at the center of it. So to go back to where we started, with young Fred Salvucci's story, when he made that promise to his grandmother to treat people better, to build more humanely, it was not at all clear he would ever get to act on it. As long as he could remember, the plan had always been for him to be a bricklayer, like his father, Guido, was. G. Salvucci and company would become G. Salvucci and son. The plan got thrown off when Fred was in junior high. His music teacher saw potential in him, and suggested he apply for the city's most prestigious public school, Boston Latin, and he got in. |||城市高速公路的看法。而弗雷德·萨尔武奇就身处风暴中心。因此，回到我们的起点，从年轻的弗雷德·萨尔武奇的故事说起，当他向外祖母许下诺言要更好地对待人们、以更有人情味的方式进行建设时，当时完全不确定他是否有机会付诸实践。在他的记忆中，原本的计划一直是让他像父亲圭多（Guido）一样成为一名泥瓦匠。“G. 萨尔武奇父子公司”（G. Salvucci and company）将变成“G. 萨尔武奇父子”（G. Salvucci and son）。当弗雷德上初中时，这个计划被打乱了。他的音乐老师看到了他的潜力，建议他申请该市最负盛名的公立学校——波士顿拉丁学校，结果他考上了。
For a stay at Latin, they give us a piece of paper and it says that I intend to go to college. So I took the thing to come and I said, gee, my consign this, I intend to go to college, this is a lie. His friends in the neighborhood weren't even planning to finish high school, let alone go to college. But Fred's mother said, look, just across the river in Cambridge, you've got MIT, one of the best engineering schools in the world. And she made this deal with him. And she said, you're going to work with your father every summer, and you learn to be
For a stay at Latin, they give us a piece of paper and it says that I intend to go to college. So I took the thing to come and I said, gee, my consign this, I intend to go to college, this is a lie. His friends in the neighborhood weren't even planning to finish high school, let alone go to college. But Fred's mother said, look, just across the river in Cambridge, you've got MIT, one of the best engineering schools in the world. And she made this deal with him. And she said, you're going to work with your father every summer, and you learn to be |||在拉丁学校报到时，学校发给我们一张纸，上面写着我打算上大学。所以我拿着那东西去找我爸说：“天哪，我签了这个，我打算上大学，这简直是个谎言。”他社区里的朋友甚至都没打算读完高中，更不用说上大学了。但弗雷德的母亲说：“听着，就在河对岸的剑桥，有麻省理工学院，那是世界上最好的工程学校之一。”她与他达成了这样一个协议。她说：“你每年夏天都要跟你父亲一起工作，学会成为
a good bricklayer. You're going to MIT if you can get in, and you learn to be a good bricklayer. You're going to MIT if you can get in and you learn to be a good civil engineer. When you finish, you can do whichever one you want. That's House Alvouchi wound up a student at MIT, the Massachusetts Institute of Technology. One day in the early 1960s, he's sitting in class and a professor starts talking about a new highway project proposed for the city, his ears perk up. It sounded an awful lot like the highway that had taken his grandmother's house. It was another piece of insanity, something that I was sure made no sense. The difference was that this time, armed with that degree in engineering, Savuchi could
a good bricklayer. You're going to MIT if you can get in, and you learn to be a good bricklayer. You're going to MIT if you can get in and you learn to be a good civil engineer. When you finish, you can do whichever one you want. That's House Alvouchi wound up a student at MIT, the Massachusetts Institute of Technology. One day in the early 1960s, he's sitting in class and a professor starts talking about a new highway project proposed for the city, his ears perk up. It sounded an awful lot like the highway that had taken his grandmother's house. It was another piece of insanity, something that I was sure made no sense. The difference was that this time, armed with that degree in engineering, Savuchi could |||一名优秀的泥瓦匠。如果你能考上，你就要去麻省理工学院，并学会成为一名优秀的泥瓦匠。如果你能考上麻省理工学院，你就要学会成为一名优秀的土木工程师。等你毕业后，你想干哪一行都行。”这就是萨尔武奇最终成为麻省理工学院（MIT）学生的经历。20世纪60年代初的一天，他正坐在课堂里，一位教授开始谈论一项为该市提议的新高速公路项目，他的耳朵立刻竖了起来。这听起来太像当年夺走他外祖母房子的那条高速公路了。这是又一场疯狂的举动，是他确信毫无意义的事情。不同的是，这一次，手握工程学位的萨尔武奇可以
actually do something about it. So, let's get the lay of the land. There will be several highways you need to keep track of in this part of the story, but they all have a common origin, a master plan for the region drawn out way back in 1948. So, if you could imagine something that highway planners often call Spoken Wheels System, so you're looking at radio roads coming out of a center circle. For the 1960s, a few pieces of that hub and Spoke system had been built. But there were still, crucially, a handful of roads needed to complete the whole scheme,
actually do something about it. So, let's get the lay of the land. There will be several highways you need to keep track of in this part of the story, but they all have a common origin, a master plan for the region drawn out way back in 1948. So, if you could imagine something that highway planners often call Spoken Wheels System, so you're looking at radio roads coming out of a center circle. For the 1960s, a few pieces of that hub and Spoke system had been built. But there were still, crucially, a handful of roads needed to complete the whole scheme, |||真正为此做点什么了。那么，让我们来了解一下当地的概况。在这个故事中，有几条高速公路你需要记住，但它们都有一个共同的起源，即早在1948年绘制的该地区总体规划。因此，如果你能想象一下高速公路规划者经常称之为“辐条车轮系统”的东西——也就是说，你看到的是从中心圆向外辐射的道路。对于20世纪60年代来说，这个“中心与辐条”系统的一些部分已经建成。但至关重要的是，要完成整个方案，仍然需要几条道路，
including something called the Interbelt. So when we think about the Interbelt Road, it's the heart of that wheel. This is the road that Savuji's professor was lecturing about, that Savuji thought was absolutely insane. And he wasn't the only one. We said no, no, no, no, no, no, it's not going to happen. Anstie Benfield lived one block from the proposed route of the highway. Right square in the middle of the line of the inner belt. The road was supposed to start in Boston, then loop around into the neighboring city of Cambridge.
including something called the Interbelt. So when we think about the Interbelt Road, it's the heart of that wheel. This is the road that Savuji's professor was lecturing about, that Savuji thought was absolutely insane. And he wasn't the only one. We said no, no, no, no, no, no, it's not going to happen. Anstie Benfield lived one block from the proposed route of the highway. Right square in the middle of the line of the inner belt. The road was supposed to start in Boston, then loop around into the neighboring city of Cambridge. |||其中包括一条被称为“内环路”（Interbelt）的东西。因此，当我们想到内环路时，它就是那个车轮的核心。这就是萨尔武奇教授在课上讲授的那条路，萨尔武奇认为它简直疯狂透顶。而且他不是唯一这么想的人。我们说：不，不，不，不，不，这绝不可能发生。安斯蒂·本菲尔德（Anstie Benfield）住在距离拟建高速公路路线仅一个街区的地方。正好处于内环路路线的正中央。这条路本应从波士顿出发，然后环绕进入邻近的剑桥市。
That is where Anstie lived, and where the whole region's highway fight would begin. This part of Cambridge was largely working class. People used to call it the Greasy Village, because historically, it had been the site of a massive factory that made soap from rendered pork fat. Then just down the road, you had the candy factories, neck awayfers, Charleston Chuse, Junior Mints, all made in Cambridge, and all giving off smells of their own.
That is where Anstie lived, and where the whole region's highway fight would begin. This part of Cambridge was largely working class. People used to call it the Greasy Village, because historically, it had been the site of a massive factory that- made soap from rendered pork fat. Then just down the road, you had the candy factories, neck awayfers, Charleston Chuse, Junior Mints, all made in Cambridge, and all giving off smells of their own. |||这就是安斯蒂居住的地方，也是整个地区高速公路之战拉开序幕的地方。剑桥的这一地区主要是工人阶级。人们过去常把它叫做“油腻村”，因为从历史上看，这里曾是一家大型工厂的所在地，该厂用熬制的猪油制造肥皂。然后顺着路往下走，你会看到糖果厂——Neck Wafers、Charleston Chews、Junior Mints，全都是在剑桥生产的，并且都散发着各自特有的气味。
So in the 1960s, you had a lot of long time residents who had come to work the industrial jobs, immigrants from Ireland, Poland, Barbados, Panama, and Black Americans coming up from the south. But this being Cambridge, Massachusetts, you also had the grad students and professors. One side was MIT, the other side was a Harvard. I mean a lot of Harvard. That meant engineers, sociologists, highly educated troublemakers of all stripes. Mayer Hayes, what is your objection to the abundance of hippies and Cambridge? The basic objection I have is the amount of them.
So in the 1960s, you had a lot of long time residents who had come to work the industrial jobs, immigrants from Ireland, Poland, Barbados, Panama, and Black Americans coming up from the south. But this being Cambridge, Massachusetts, you also had the grad students and professors. One side was MIT, the other side was a Harvard. I mean a lot of Harvard. That meant engineers, sociologists, highly educated troublemakers of all stripes. Mayer Hayes, what is your objection to the abundance of hippies and Cambridge? The basic objection I have is the amount of them. |||所以在20世纪60年代，这里有很多为了工业工作而来的长期居民，包括来自爱尔兰、波兰、巴巴多斯、巴拿马的移民，以及从南方来到这里的美国黑人。但既然这里是马萨诸塞州的剑桥，你还会遇到研究生和教授。一边是麻省理工学院，另一边是哈佛大学。我是说，有大量的哈佛人。这意味着工程师、社会学家以及形形色色受过高等教育的“麻烦制造者”。梅尔·海斯（Mayer Hayes），你对剑桥充斥着嬉皮士有什么异议？我最大的异议就是他们的数量太多了。
Noam Chomsky was lecturing at MIT. Joan Bias was singing protest anthems in Harvard Square. Women's Liberation, the Vietnam War, it was pretty fertile ground for an activist movement. And a highway was the kind of issue that could bring everyone together from Catholic priests and housewives to radical lefties and college students.
Noam Chomsky was lecturing at MIT. Joan Bias was singing protest anthems in Harvard Square. Women's Liberation, the Vietnam War, it was pretty fertile ground for an activist movement. And a highway was the kind of issue that could bring everyone together from Catholic priests and housewives to radical lefties and college students. |||诺姆·乔姆斯基（Noam Chomsky）当时在麻省理工学院讲学。琼·贝兹（Joan Baez）在哈佛广场高唱抗议赞歌。妇女解放运动、越南战争，这里是开展激进运动的绝佳土壤。而高速公路正是那种能够将所有人——从天主教神父、家庭主妇到激进左翼分子和大学生——团结在一起的议题。
I had my graduate degree in urban studies and I had a lot of energy and I needed something to do. Well, low and behold, within a year of buying that house on Chestnut Street, they started planning to knock the thing down. At that point, I went into action. In early 1966, Anstie collected over a thousand signatures from other residents along the inner belt route. I took the Iowa signatures and nailed them to the wooden doors of City Hall.
I had my graduate degree in urban studies and I had a lot of energy and I needed something to do. Well, low and behold, within a year of buying that house on Chestnut Street, they started planning to knock the thing down. At that point, I went into action. In early 1966, Anstie collected over a thousand signatures from other residents along the inner belt route. I took the Iowa signatures and nailed them to the wooden doors of City Hall. |||我拥有城市研究的硕士学位，精力充沛，正需要找点事情做。好吧，真是无巧不成书，就在我买下栗树街那栋房子的不到一年内，他们就开始计划把它拆了。从那时起，我采取了行动。1966年初，安斯蒂收集了内环路沿线其他居民的一千多个签名。我拿着这些签名，把它们钉在了市政厅的木门上。
There's a picture of this in the local paper, the Cambridge Chronicle, with Anstie carrying her two-year-old daughter on her back. But then two weeks they changed the wooden doors to glass. But the point was made. The residents of Cambridge would not go quietly. Around this same time, Fred Selvucci set aside his bricklaying dreams for good. He took a job as a transportation planner with the city of Boston. His boss, the mayor, actually supported the inter belt.
There's a picture of this in the local paper, the Cambridge Chronicle, with Anstie carrying her two-year-old daughter on her back. But then two weeks they changed the wooden doors to glass. But the point was made. The residents of Cambridge would not go quietly. Around this same time, Fred Selvucci set aside his bricklaying dreams for good. He took a job as a transportation planner with the city of Boston. His boss, the mayor, actually supported the inter belt. |||当地报纸《剑桥纪事报》（Cambridge Chronicle）上有一张照片，记录了这一幕：安斯蒂背着她两岁的女儿。但两周后，他们就把木门换成了玻璃门。不过，他们的态度已经表明了：剑桥居民绝不会默默无闻地束手就擒。大约在同一时期，弗雷德·萨尔武奇彻底放下了他的泥瓦匠梦想。他在波士顿市政府找到了一份交通规划师的工作。他的老板——市长，实际上是支持内环路的。
But Selvuchi found that many of his fellow city planners did not, so they started to meet. There was no game plan from the beginning. We just sort of stumbled into it. One of those rogue city planners started writing pieces about the highway for the Cambridge Chronicle. But why is Cambridge got its head in the sand? Why aren't we proposing alternatives to questions about whether the road ought to be built at all? But certainly if you're going to build it, it doesn't have to be this bad. And one day, a local priest reached out to the group and said, gee, you are saying things that we are thinking in the neighborhood, but you've got technical skills that we don't have.
But Selvuchi found that many of his fellow city planners did not, so they started to meet. There was no game plan from the beginning. We just sort of stumbled into it. One of those rogue city planners started writing pieces about the highway for the Cambridge Chronicle. But why is Cambridge got its head in the sand? Why aren't we proposing alternatives to questions about whether the road ought to be built at all? But certainly if you're going to build it, it doesn't have to be this bad. And one day, a local priest reached out to the group and said, gee, you are saying things that we are thinking in the neighborhood, but you've got technical skills that we don't have. |||但萨尔武奇发现他的许多城市规划同行并不支持，于是他们开始开会。一开始并没有什么周密的计划。我们只是稀里糊涂地撞进来的。其中一位“叛逆”的城市规划师开始为《剑桥纪事报》撰写关于这条高速公路的文章。“为什么剑桥要当鸵鸟？为什么我们不提出替代方案来回答这条路到底应不应该修的问题？但退一步讲，如果你非要修，也不至于修得这么糟糕。”有一天，当地的一位神父联系了这个小组成员并说道：“天哪，你们说出了我们社区居民心里想的话，但你们拥有我们所不具备的技术技能。
You'd be willing to work with us. That call would change the course of the movement. All of a sudden, we like unpaid consultants working for the neighborhood. And I want to stress just how radical this was. For years, states around the country had been telling residents, trust us, we know what's best, we have the experts. Now here were those same experts saying, no, the state is wrong. Eventually, Savucci's group got a name, urban planning aid.
You'd be willing to work with us. That call would change the course of the movement. All of a sudden, we like unpaid consultants working for the neighborhood. And I want to stress just how radical this was. For years, states around the country had been telling residents, trust us, we know what's best, we have the experts. Now here were those same experts saying, no, the state is wrong. Eventually, Savucci's group got a name, urban planning aid. |||你们愿意和我们合作吗？”这个电话改变了这场运动的走向。突然之间，我们就像是为社区工作的无偿顾问。我想强调的是，这在当时是多么激进。多年来，全国各地的州政府一直对居民说：“相信我们，我们知道什么最好，我们有专家。”现在，正是这些专家在说：“不，州政府错了。”最终，萨尔武奇的小组有了一个名字：城市规划援助（Urban Planning Aid）。
Did it feel like you're almost crossing enemy lines or something? I mean, you're working for the city and then you're moonlighting, helping residents and communities organize to oppose the city and state. Were those things intentioned for you? I'm not by nature a sneaky person. So I sent a memo to my boss and said, look, at night, this is what I'm doing. I'm working with people who don't believe in these highways. If you have a problem, let me know and I'll find another job. He said, well, no, we don't want you
Did it feel like you're almost crossing enemy lines or something? I mean, you're working for the city and then you're moonlighting, helping residents and communities organize to oppose the city and state. Were those things intentioned for you? I'm not by nature a sneaky person. So I sent a memo to my boss and said, look, at night, this is what I'm doing. I'm working with people who don't believe in these highways. If you have a problem, let me know and I'll find another job. He said, well, no, we don't want you |||当时有没有感觉自己就像是在越过敌方防线之类的？我的意思是，你为市政府工作，然后又在业余时间兼职，帮助居民和社区组织起来反对市政府和州政府。这些事情对你来说有冲突吗？我天生不是一个偷偷摸摸的人。所以我给老板发了一份备忘录，说道：“听着，晚上我在做这些事。我正在和那些不相信这些高速公路的人一起工作。如果你觉得有问题，告诉我，我去找另一份工作。”他说：“哦，不，我们不想让你
to go, but we want you to stop doing what you're doing. And so you don't have an option. It's my life. I do what I believe in. They said, I am crazy, but fine. Do what you do. At that time, Savuchi was not convinced the interbelt could be stopped. You're the governor, big construction companies, labor unions, not to mention a decade of unstoppable growth in the interstate system, all pushing to make the road happen.
to go, but we want you to stop doing what you're doing. And so you don't have an option. It's my life. I do what I believe in. They said, I am crazy, but fine. Do what you do. At that time, Savuchi was not convinced the interbelt could be stopped. You're the governor, big construction companies, labor unions, not to mention a decade of unstoppable growth in the interstate system, all pushing to make the road happen. |||走，但我们希望你停止你现在做的事。”所以你别无选择。这是我的人生。我做我坚信的事情。他们说我疯了，但也只能随我便。去做你该做的事吧。当时，萨尔武奇并不确信内环路能够被阻止。州政府、大型建筑公司、工会，更不用说过去十年间势不可挡的州际公路系统的增长，都在极力推动这条路的建成。
So Savuchi was more focused on finding a way to make it less destructive, so fewer families would have to lose their homes, like his grandmother had. That might sound like a modest aim, but it turned into a battle. This audio is from a Cambridge City Council meeting in 1966, discussing the impact of various roots. First of all, I'd like to give a general description of the routes that have been considered as too possible or feasible all in its to the Brookline Elm route using the criteria which has been set up. The route that the state was proposing was terrible and savuch's opinion. It went straight through the neighborhood, the old Greasy Village.
So Savuchi was more focused on finding a way to make it less destructive, so fewer families would have to lose their homes, like his grandmother had. That might sound like a modest aim, but it turned into a battle. This audio is from a Cambridge City Council meeting in 1966, discussing the impact of various roots. First of all, I'd like to give a general description of the routes that have been considered as too possible or feasible all in its to the Brookline Elm route using the criteria which has been set up. The route that the state was proposing was terrible and savuch's opinion. It went straight through the neighborhood, the old Greasy Village. |||因此，萨尔武奇当时更专注于寻找一种方法，使其破坏性减小，这样就能有更少的家庭像他外祖母那样失去家园。这听起来可能是一个微不足道的目标，但它演变成了一场恶战。这段音频来自1966年剑桥市议会的一次会议，讨论各种路线的影响。首先，我想对根据既定标准被认为可行或可能的路线做一个总体描述，包括布鲁克兰-埃尔姆路线。在萨尔武奇看来，州政府提议的路线糟糕透顶。它径直穿过了那个社区——也就是老“油腻村”。
If the plan was built, a sleepy one-way street lined with houses would be turned into an eight-lane elevated highway. The width that's required just for the structure would be roughly 135 feet. But there was a logical alternative, which Savucci's group was able to actually map out and publish. It was just south of the original route, running along the path of old railroad tracks. This is referred to as Scheme E or M. It would take a fraction of the number of homes, but in a little twist of irony for Savucci, it would go through the campus of MIT. And the present needs of MIT need to be considered.
If the plan was built, a sleepy one-way street lined with houses would be turned into an eight-lane elevated highway. The width that's required just for the structure would be roughly 135 feet. But there was a logical alternative, which Savucci's group was able to actually map out and publish. It was just south of the original route, running along the path of old railroad tracks. This is referred to as Scheme E or M. It would take a fraction of the number of homes, but in a little twist of irony for Savucci, it would go through the campus of MIT. And the present needs of MIT need to be considered. |||如果按照这个计划修建，一条两旁林立着住宅、安静的单行道将被变成一条八车道的高架高速公路。仅结构本身所需的宽度就约为135英尺。但有一个符合逻辑的替代方案，萨尔武奇的小组成功地绘制并将其公之于众。它位于原路线的正南方，沿着旧铁轨的路线延伸。这就是所谓的E方案或M方案。它所拆迁的房屋数量只是前者的极小一部分，但对萨尔武奇来说带有一点讽刺意味的是，它将穿过麻省理工学院的校园。而麻省理工学院目前的需要必须予以考虑。
This of course set many MIT types against him and this alternate route. Savuchi recalls one critical moment, really a very Cambridge moment, when faculty from MIT and Harvard basically wound up debating the route issue, upstairs at the worst house in Harvard Square. On the neighborhood side was a Harvard economist named Kenneth Galbrith.
This of course set many MIT types against him and this alternate route. Savuchi recalls one critical moment, really a very Cambridge moment, when faculty from MIT and Harvard basically wound up debating the route issue, upstairs at the worst house in Harvard Square. On the neighborhood side was a Harvard economist named Kenneth Galbrith. |||这当然让许多麻省理工学院的人反对他和这条替代路线。萨尔武奇回忆起一个关键时刻——一个非常具有剑桥特色的时刻：麻省理工学院和哈佛大学的教职员工基本上最终在哈佛广场最糟糕的房子的楼上，就路线问题展开了辩论。站在社区一边的是一位名叫肯尼斯·加尔布雷思（Kenneth Galbraith）的哈佛经济学家。
Now Galbrith had just flown in from Switzerland. That meant that Salvucci and another organizer named Jim Mori had only a few minutes to brief him on the details of the issue. So he's just come off of a plane and he's blurry eyed and he's bounding up the steps to it at a time. Galbirth, by the way, was six feet eight inches tall. Jim Mori was about five foot six and he's running to keep up with Galbraith and I'm two steps behind him and talk about the elevator talk, Maury briefs Galbirth in the space that it takes this giant to go two steps at a time from the ground floor
Now Galbrith had just flown in from Switzerland. That meant that Salvucci and another organizer named Jim Mori had only a few minutes to brief him on the details of the issue. So he's just come off of a plane and he's blurry eyed and he's bounding up the steps to it at a time. Galbirth, by the way, was six feet eight inches tall. Jim Mori was about five foot six and he's running to keep up with Galbraith and I'm two steps behind him and talk about the elevator talk, Maury briefs Galbirth in the space that it takes this giant to go two steps at a time from the ground floor |||当时加尔布雷思刚从瑞士飞抵波士顿。这意味着萨尔武奇和另一位组织者吉姆·莫里（Jim Mori）只有几分钟时间向他简要介绍该问题的细节。他刚下飞机，睡眼惺忪，大步流星地一级一级往台阶上跑。顺便说一句，加尔布雷思身高六英尺八英寸（约2.03米）。吉姆·莫里身高约五英尺六英寸（约1.68米），他一路小跑才能跟上加尔布雷思，而我则落后他两步。说到电梯演讲，莫里向加尔布雷思做简报的时间，也就是这个巨人从一楼一次跨两步走到
to the second floor of the worst house. So Galbirth says, I think I got it. The meeting begins and a professor from MIT speaks first. You basically said, look, I've been living here for a while now, and we keep trying to elect more progressive school committees and more progressive city councils. And every year, those people that is the blue-collar population get the majority.
to the second floor of the worst house. So Galbirth says, I think I got it. The meeting begins and a professor from MIT speaks first. You basically said, look, I've been living here for a while now, and we keep trying to elect more progressive school committees and more progressive city councils. And every year, those people that is the blue-collar population get the majority. |||那栋最差的房子的二楼所需的那么一点时间。于是加尔布雷思说：“我想我明白了。”会议开始，一位麻省理工学院的教授首先发言。你基本上是说：“听着，我在这里住了一段时间了，我们一直在努力选举更具进取心的学校委员会和更具进取心的市议会。而每年，那些人——也就是蓝领阶层——总是占多数。”
And we have Lausie education and Lausie government. And maybe just maybe if this highway knocks out 2500 dwelling units and associated waters, maybe we'll win the next election. The guy sitting next to him then makes a similar argument that the road should go through the neighborhood, not the campus. At which point Galworth picks up his arm, which seems to almost reach the other side of the room. Points of finger and says, only a moral imbusel would articulate such a cynical argument. We're living in a country that's being torn apart by race, in a city that's being torn apart
And we have Lausie education and Lausie government. And maybe just maybe if this highway knocks out 2500 dwelling units and associated waters, maybe we'll win the next election. The guy sitting next to him then makes a similar argument that the road should go through the neighborhood, not the campus. At which point Galworth picks up his arm, which seems to almost reach the other side of the room. Points of finger and says, only a moral imbusel would articulate such a cynical argument. We're living in a country that's being torn apart by race, in a city that's being torn apart |||“而我们却有着糟糕的教育和糟糕的政府。也许，只是也许，如果这条高速公路摧毁了2500套住宅以及相关的水域，说不定我们就能赢得下一次选举。”坐在他旁边的那个人随后提出了类似的论点，即道路应该穿过社区，而不是校园。就在这时，加尔布雷思抬起手臂，他的手臂似乎几乎能够到房间的另一头。他指着对方说道：“只有道德沦丧的白痴才会说出如此愤世嫉俗的论调。我们生活在一个因种族而撕裂的国家，生活在一个因
by racial strife, and somehow, through some magic that none of us in this room was smart enough to understand, there's an integrated neighborhood here in Cambridge where people are getting long reasonably well, and they're low income people and minorities, and how on Earth could we ever think of destroying this precious resource and he just carries the day. carries the day. These debates over the route were strategically important. They bought time, drew attention and made sure that the whole city of Cambridge had a stake in the issue. As long as the road could go anywhere, everyone had a reason to oppose it.
by racial strife, and somehow, through some magic that none of us in this room was smart enough to understand, there's an integrated neighborhood here in Cambridge where people are getting long reasonably well, and they're low income people and minorities, and how on Earth could we ever think of destroying this precious resource and he just carries the day. carries the day. These debates over the route were strategically important. They bought time, drew attention and made sure that the whole city of Cambridge had a stake in the issue. As long as the road could go anywhere, everyone had a reason to oppose it. |||种族冲突而撕裂的城市里，不知通过什么魔法——在座没有一个人聪明到能理解这种魔法——剑桥这里竟然有一个多元融合的社区，那里的人们相处得相当融洽，他们是低收入人群和少数族裔，我们怎么能哪怕有一丝一毫的想法去摧毁这宝贵的资源呢？”他最终说服了所有人，赢得了辩论。这些关于路线的辩论在战略上至关重要。它们争取了时间，吸引了注意力，并确保了整个剑桥市都在这一议题中拥有切身利益。只要这条路可能修在任何地方，每个人就都有理由反对它。
But ultimately the fate of the interte could not be decided in Cambridge. This fight was bound for higher places, the governor's office, the White House. The trouble is, the occupants of those high offices could always change, and that would force the activists to change too. This election coverage is coming to you from WGBHTV and WGBHFM Boston. 1966 was an election year for governor, and the man running to keep that job was named John Volpe. And he was a highway guy. Before becoming governor, Volpe had owned a major construction firm and then served as the very first leader of the Federal Highway
But ultimately the fate of the interte could not be decided in Cambridge. This fight was bound for higher places, the governor's office, the White House. The trouble is, the occupants of those high offices could always change, and that would force the activists to change too. This election coverage is coming to you from WGBHTV and WGBHFM Boston. 1966 was an election year for governor, and the man running to keep that job was named John Volpe. And he was a highway guy. Before becoming governor, Volpe had owned a major construction firm and then served as the very first leader of the Federal Highway |||但归根结底，内环路的命运无法在剑桥决定。这场斗争注定要走向更高层的地方：州长办公室、白宫。问题是，这些高级官职的执掌者总是会发生变化，这也会迫使活动人士随之改变。这次选举报道由波士顿WGBH电视台和WGBH广播电台为您播报。1966年是州长选举年，竞选连任该职位的人名叫约翰·沃尔佩（John Volpe）。他是个名副其实的“道路迷”。在担任州长之前，沃尔佩曾拥有一家大型建筑公司，随后担任了联邦公路局的第一任负责人。
Administration under Eisenhower. In Cambridge today, there is a mural that shows angry residents standing in front of a bulldozer. It's a little hard to tell just by looking, but if you ask, ants, they bend field. The man in the bulldozer is It's a little hard to tell just by looking, but if you ask, ants, you bend field. The man in the bulldozer is no other than... Governor Volpy. We're going to Holpy headquarters directly at this point. The election was November 8th. Urban planning aid scrambled to publish new data about the highways
Administration under Eisenhower. In Cambridge today, there is a mural that shows angry residents standing in front of a bulldozer. It's a little hard to tell just by looking, but if you ask, ants, they bend field. The man in the bulldozer is It's a little hard to tell just by looking, but if you ask, ants, you bend field. The man in the bulldozer is no other than... Governor Volpy. We're going to Holpy headquarters directly at this point. The election was November 8th. Urban planning aid scrambled to publish new data about the highways |||在艾森豪威尔手下供职。如今在剑桥，有一幅壁画描绘了愤怒的居民站在推土机前的场景。光看外表很难辨认，但如果你去问安斯蒂·本菲尔德的话。推土机里的人是……光看外表很难辨认，但如果你去问安斯蒂·本菲尔德的话。推土机里的人不是别人，正是……沃尔佩州长。我们现在直接前往沃尔佩竞选总部。选举日是11月8日。城市规划援助组织匆忙公布了关于高速公路的新数据
just beforehand, but it didn't matter. And joy is really broken out here at Volpe, Richardson headquarters. Volpe was here to stay. During the next four years, we will try to work as hard if not harder than we have during the past two years. And again, as I say, place Massachusetts number one in all fields of endeavor. Thank you very much. So with the highway supporter firmly entrenched in the governor's office, the anti-highway activists now took their fight further up the ladder to Washington.
just beforehand, but it didn't matter. And joy is really broken out here at Volpe, Richardson headquarters. Volpe was here to stay. During the next four years, we will try to work as hard if not harder than we have during the past two years. And again, as I say, place Massachusetts number one in all fields of endeavor. Thank you very much. So with the highway supporter firmly entrenched in the governor's office, the anti-highway activists now took their fight further up the ladder to Washington. |||就在选举前夕，但这一切都无济于事。在沃尔佩和理查德森的竞选总部，欢乐的气氛已经彻底爆发。沃尔佩将继续留任。在接下来的四年里，我们将尽最大努力工作，甚至比过去两年更加努力。再次如我所说，让马萨诸塞州在各项事业中都名列前茅。非常感谢。因此，随着坚定的高速公路支持者稳坐州长办公室，反高速公路活动人士现在将他们的斗争提升到了更高的层级——华盛顿。
And within a year we had four or five busloads of kids to Washington. And oh yes, I can tell you, we had signs that said Cambridge is a city not a highway and all the kids started chanting Cambridge is a city not a highway they will never build roads through our homes and we would haul these songs out all the way to Washington from Cambridge. Oh, that ride was amazing. Ansty Benfield showed me another newspaper clipping. Three kids sitting on the grass outside the Capitol with the headline, Lollipop Lobby. That was on the Washington Post from page. I mean, that was the kind of thing that drew attention to our objections. Yeah, it's hard to say no to 150 singing children.
And within a year we had four or five busloads of kids to Washington. And oh yes, I can tell you, we had signs that said Cambridge is a city not a highway and all the kids started chanting Cambridge is a city not a highway they will never build roads through our homes and we would haul these songs out all the way to Washington from Cambridge. Oh, that ride was amazing. Ansty Benfield showed me another newspaper clipping. Three kids sitting on the grass outside the Capitol with the headline, Lollipop Lobby. That was on the Washington Post from page. I mean, that was the kind of thing that drew attention to our objections. Yeah, it's hard to say no to 150 singing children. |||不到一年的时间里，我们用四五辆大巴车载着孩子们去了华盛顿。哦，是的，我可以告诉你，我们举着标语，上面写着“剑桥是城市，不是高速公路”，孩子们开始高呼：“剑桥是城市，不是高速公路，他们休想在我们家园上修路！”我们就这样一路把这些口号从剑桥带到了华盛顿。哦，那次旅程太棒了。安斯蒂·本菲尔德向我展示了另一份剪报。三个孩子坐在国会大厦外的草坪上，头条标题是“棒棒糖说客”。那是在《华盛顿邮报》的头版。我的意思是，正是这种事情吸引了人们对我们反对意见的关注。是的，很难对150个唱歌的孩子说“不”。
That's exactly the idea. And the strategy paid off. The Lyndon Johnson administration ordered a pair of new studies on the interbelt, questioning both where the belt should go and whether it should be built at all. It was a huge win for Benfield, Savuji, and all the anti-highway folks. But just as those studies began, the whole game was turned on its head. It's time for new leadership for the United States of America!
That's exactly the idea. And the strategy paid off. The Lyndon Johnson administration ordered a pair of new studies on the interbelt, questioning both where the belt should go and whether it should be built at all. It was a huge win for Benfield, Savuji, and all the anti-highway folks. But just as those studies began, the whole game was turned on its head. It's time for new leadership for the United States of America! |||这正是我们的意图。这一策略收到了成效。林登·约翰逊政府下令对内环路进行两项新的研究，既质疑内环路应该修在哪里，又质疑它是否根本就不该修建。这对本菲尔德、萨尔武奇以及所有反高速公路的人士来说是一场巨大的胜利。但就在这些研究刚开始时，整个局势却来了个180度大转弯。是时候为美利坚合众国带来新的领导层了！
In 1968, Richard Nixon was running for president. And in the words of one Boston Globe reporter, Governor John Volpy was running right after him. Volpy was tired of Democrats in Washington holding up the inter-belt, so he set out to replace them with himself, and it worked. When Richard Nixon becomes president, he immediately taps Volpe to be the head of transportation in DC. Secretary of Transportation for the whole country.
In 1968, Richard Nixon was running for president. And in the words of one Boston Globe reporter, Governor John Volpy was running right after him. Volpy was tired of Democrats in Washington holding up the inter-belt, so he set out to replace them with himself, and it worked. When Richard Nixon becomes president, he immediately taps Volpe to be the head of transportation in DC. Secretary of Transportation for the whole country. |||1968年，理查德·尼克松正在竞选总统。用《波士顿环球报》一位记者的话来说，约翰·沃尔佩州长紧随其后。沃尔佩厌倦了华盛顿的民主党人对内环路的阻挠，于是他着手让自己取代他们，并且成功了。当理查德·尼克松成为总统时，他立即任命沃尔佩为华盛顿特区交通负责人。全国的交通部长。
Volpe gave a speech after the election in which he spoke about the inter belt and told the crowd with confidence. There's a new administration taking office in Washington, and I think we'll start to see things happen. Again, author Carolyn Crocket. So Volby gets whisked away, and quickly his second-in-command becomes governor. All of a sudden, the activists' allies in Washington had been replaced by their foe in Massachusetts, and their foe in Massachusetts had been replaced by a question mark. Didn't know anything about him.
Volpe gave a speech after the election in which he spoke about the inter belt and told the crowd with confidence. There's a new administration taking office in Washington, and I think we'll start to see things happen. Again, author Carolyn Crocket. So Volby gets whisked away, and quickly his second-in-command becomes governor. All of a sudden, the activists' allies in Washington had been replaced by their foe in Massachusetts, and their foe in Massachusetts had been replaced by a question mark. Didn't know anything about him. |||沃尔佩在选举后发表了一次演讲，其中谈到了内环路，并充满信心地对人群说：“华盛顿新政府即将上任，我认为我们将开始看到事情有所进展。”作者卡罗琳·克罗克特再次说道。于是沃尔佩被调走，他的副手很快成为了州长。突然之间，活动人士在华盛顿的盟友被他们在马萨诸塞州的死敌所取代，而他们在马萨诸塞州的死敌又被一个未知数所取代。对这个人一无所知。
The question mark's name was Francis Sargent. So when Francis Sargent would become a governor in the surprise, almost light of hand move. The thought on the ground was, hmm, we have maybe an opening here. At the same time that the debate over the inter belt is playing out in Cambridge, work is already beginning on another new highway in Boston. It's called the Southwest Expressway, and it's important because when linked together, the Southwest Expressway and the inter Belt would carry traffic from Interstate 95 straight through the city.
The question mark's name was Francis Sargent. So when Francis Sargent would become a governor in the surprise, almost light of hand move. The thought on the ground was, hmm, we have maybe an opening here. At the same time that the debate over the inter belt is playing out in Cambridge, work is already beginning on another new highway in Boston. It's called the Southwest Expressway, and it's important because when linked together, the Southwest Expressway and the inter Belt would carry traffic from Interstate 95 straight through the city. |||这个未知数的名字叫弗朗西斯·萨金特（Francis Sargent）。因此，当弗朗西斯·萨金特通过一次出人意料、几乎像是变戏法般的举动成为州长时。基层人们的想法是：嗯，我们这里可能出现了一个突破口。就在剑桥围绕内环路的争论正酣之际，波士顿另一条新高速公路的建设已经拉开帷幕。它被称为“西南高速公路”（Southwest Expressway），这一点很重要，因为西南高速公路与内环路连接起来后，将把来自95号州际公路的车流直接引入并穿过城市。
I-95 is the busiest interstate in the whole national system. And by 1968, when Nixon is elected president, the road already runs through almost every major city on the east coast. It has cut through Miami's historic black neighborhood of Overtown. It has cut through New York along the Cross-Bronk's Expressway. It has gone through New Haven, Connecticut, Providence, Rhode Island, and now its two strands of concrete have literally arrived at the edges of Boston where they are waiting for the gates to open. The person holding the keys, so to speak, was the brand new governor of Massachusetts, Francis Sargent.
I-95 is the busiest interstate in the whole national system. And by 1968, when Nixon is elected president, the road already runs through almost every major city on the east coast. It has cut through Miami's historic black neighborhood of Overtown. It has cut through New York along the Cross-Bronk's Expressway. It has gone through New Haven, Connecticut, Providence, Rhode Island, and now its two strands of concrete have literally arrived at the edges of Boston where they are waiting for the gates to open. The person holding the keys, so to speak, was the brand new governor of Massachusetts, Francis Sargent. |||95号州际公路是整个国家系统中最为繁忙的州际公路。到1968年尼克松当选总统时，这条公路已经穿过了东海岸几乎所有主要城市。它穿过了迈阿密历史悠久的黑人社区奥弗托恩（Overtown）。它沿着跨布朗克斯高速公路（Cross-Bronx Expressway）穿过了纽约。它穿过了康涅狄格州的纽黑文、罗德岛州的普罗维登斯，现在，它的两条混凝土路段简直已经延伸到了波士顿的边缘，正等待着大门开启。可以说，掌握钥匙的人正是马萨诸塞州的新任州长弗朗西斯·萨金特。
To change his mind, it would take more than just activists in Cambridge, plus some rebellious city planners. It would take a coalition, including all the neighborhoods along the Southwest Expressway. So we had this very sophisticated strategy. We went on to the gas station, got a road map. And with crayon, we mocked out the route of the proposed interstates. And we just went neighborhood by neighborhood where the crayon hawk went. I went to a meeting where a group called Urban Planning Aid showed us these God for Second Plant and it was stunning.
To change his mind, it would take more than just activists in Cambridge, plus some rebellious city planners. It would take a coalition, including all the neighborhoods along the Southwest Expressway. So we had this very sophisticated strategy. We went on to the gas station, got a road map. And with crayon, we mocked out the route of the proposed interstates. And we just went neighborhood by neighborhood where the crayon hawk went. I went to a meeting where a group called Urban Planning Aid showed us these God for Second Plant and it was stunning. |||要改变他的心意，仅仅依靠剑桥的活动人士加上一些叛逆的城市规划师是远远不够的。这需要一个联盟，包括西南高速公路沿线的所有社区。因此我们制定了一个非常复杂的策略。我们去加油站拿了一张公路地图。然后用蜡笔在地图上勾勒出拟建州际公路的路线。随着蜡笔划过的路线，我们走访了一个又一个社区。我去参加了一个会议，会上一个名为“城市规划援助”的组织向我们展示了这些该死的规划图，实在太震撼了。
Anne Hirschfeng was one of many, many people who heard a version of that presentation. It included drawings of the highways and maps with dark lines superimposed on them. Images that could activate the imagination. Make you realize that the house you had just repainted or the block where you knew everyone's kids that those things could be taken away and paved over and no one even needed to so much as ask your opinion. When the presentation was done,
Anne Hirschfeng was one of many, many people who heard a version of that presentation. It included drawings of the highways and maps with dark lines superimposed on them. Images that could activate the imagination. Make you realize that the house you had just repainted or the block where you knew everyone's kids that those things could be taken away and paved over and no one even needed to so much as ask your opinion. When the presentation was done, |||安·赫施芬格（Anne Hirschfeng）是众多听过该演示文稿的人之一。其中包含了高速公路的图纸以及叠加了深色线条的地图。这些画面能够激发想象力。让你意识到，你刚刚重新粉刷过的房子，或者你认识那里每个孩子的街区，这些东西都可能被强行征收并铺上柏油路面，而甚至没有人需要征求你的意见。演示结束后，
the person sitting next to Anne volunteered to help spread the word. Then I put up my hand. I thought I'm gonna do it too. The presentation was done, the person sitting next to Anne, volunteered to help spread the word. Then I put up my hand. I thought I'm gonna do it too. The Southwest Expressway would cut across three neighborhoods, each with its own character. First, it would enter Boston through a largely white working class neighborhood called Jamaica Plain.
the person sitting next to Anne volunteered to help spread the word. Then I put up my hand. I thought I'm gonna do it too. The presentation was done, the person sitting next to Anne, volunteered to help spread the word. Then I put up my hand. I thought I'm gonna do it too. The Southwest Expressway would cut across three neighborhoods, each with its own character. First, it would enter Boston through a largely white working class neighborhood called Jamaica Plain. |||坐在安旁边的那个人自愿帮忙传播消息。接着我举起了手。心想我也要加入。演示结束后，坐在安旁边的那个人自愿帮忙传播消息。接着我举起了手。心想我也要加入。西南高速公路将穿过三个社区，每个社区都有其独特的风貌。首先，它将穿过一个主要是白人工人阶级的社区进入波士顿，这个社区被称为牙买加平原（Jamaica Plain）。
The state started clearing land there in 1966. I actually went from house to house and took pictures of the abandoned houses. But there were still gardens growing in the backyards, flowers. Yeah, it looked like a normal neighborhood except there weren't people. The next neighborhood in the highways path was Roxbury, the historic center of black culture in Boston. Everybody knows that there are going to be 1,500 jobs that would be taken. Everybody knows that there will be another 400 homes that will be taken. We know that there is going to be... Like in so many cities, Boston's black residents were facing perhaps the greatest impact from highways. Because Roxbury is where the Southwest Expressway and the Inter Belt, the Spoke and the Hub,
The state started clearing land there in 1966. I actually went from house to house and took pictures of the abandoned houses. But there were still gardens growing in the backyards, flowers. Yeah, it looked like a normal neighborhood except there weren't people. The next neighborhood in the highways path was Roxbury, the historic center of black culture in Boston. Everybody knows that there are going to be 1,500 jobs that would be taken. Everybody knows that there will be another 400 homes that will be taken. We know that there is going to be... Like in so many cities, Boston's black residents were facing perhaps the greatest impact from highways. Because Roxbury is where the Southwest Expressway and the Inter Belt, the Spoke and the Hub, |||州政府于1966年开始在那里清理土地。我实际上挨家挨户去给那些被废弃的房屋拍了照。但后院里仍然长着花园和鲜花。是的，它看起来就像一个正常的社区，只是里面没有人。高速公路路线上的下一个社区是罗克斯伯里（Roxbury），波士顿黑人文化的历史中心。每个人都知道将有1500个工作岗位被夺走。每个人都知道还将有400栋房屋被征收。我们知道将会……就像在许多城市一样，波士顿的黑人居民面临着来自高速公路的巨大冲击。因为罗克斯伯里正是西南高速公路与内环路——也就是辐条与车轮中心——
they were going to meet in a towering five-story interchange. The fact that 150 acres of developer land in the Roxbury Jamaica Plain Area is going to be taken by this four-lane highway. On the other side of that interchange was a third neighborhood, the south end. Here the city started to get more dense, with rows of old brown stones that were pretty run down in those days. It was a neighborhood approximately one mile square that would have been entirely surrounded
they were going to meet in a towering five-story interchange. The fact that 150 acres of developer land in the Roxbury Jamaica Plain Area is going to be taken by this four-lane highway. On the other side of that interchange was a third neighborhood, the south end. Here the city started to get more dense, with rows of old brown stones that were pretty run down in those days. It was a neighborhood approximately one mile square that would have been entirely surrounded |||将要汇合于一座高耸的五层立交桥的地方。罗克斯伯里-牙买加平原地区的150英亩开发土地将被这条四车道高速公路占用的事实。在该立交桥的另一侧是第三个社区，即南区（South End）。在这里，城市开始变得更加密集，一排排老旧的棕色石屋在当时已经相当破败。这是一个面积约为一平方英里的社区，将被
by highways. Those voices you just heard, Tom Corrigan, Chuck Turner, and Ken Cookemeier, were to all end up involved with a new umbrella organization, the Greater Boston Committee on the Transportation Crisis, or GBC for short. But as the coalition grew, it also became more unwieldy. Each neighborhood had its own particular issues with the highways and its own particular culture. There's a story of Chuck Turner showing up for a protest in a mostly Italian neighborhood
by highways. Those voices you just heard, Tom Corrigan, Chuck Turner, and Ken Cookemeier, were to all end up involved with a new umbrella organization, the Greater Boston Committee on the Transportation Crisis, or GBC for short. But as the coalition grew, it also became more unwieldy. Each neighborhood had its own particular issues with the highways and its own particular culture. There's a story of Chuck Turner showing up for a protest in a mostly Italian neighborhood |||高速公路完全包围。你刚才听到的那些声音——汤姆·科里根（Tom Corrigan）、查克·特纳（Chuck Turner）和肯·库克迈尔（Ken Cookemeier）——最终都参与了一个新的伞形组织，即大波士顿交通危机委员会（Greater Boston Committee on the Transportation Crisis，简称GBC）。但随着联盟的扩大，它也变得越来越难以管理。每个社区都有其关于高速公路的特定问题和独特的文化。有一个故事说，查克·特纳在一个主要由意大利人居住的社区参加抗议活动时，
dressed in a disheaky and carrying a poster of Malcolm X. Some residents were grateful for the solidarity. Some walked away right there. To help unify all the various factions, the GBC took a very simple position. No new highways in Greater Boston period. The days of debating routes were officially over. And the strategy of this new group was right in the name. Make this an issue for all of Greater Boston, not just three neighborhoods.
dressed in a disheaky and carrying a poster of Malcolm X. Some residents were grateful for the solidarity. Some walked away right there. To help unify all the various factions, the GBC took a very simple position. No new highways in Greater Boston period. The days of debating routes were officially over. And the strategy of this new group was right in the name. Make this an issue for all of Greater Boston, not just three neighborhoods. |||衣着邋遢，手里拿着一张马尔科姆·X的画像。一些居民对这种声援表示感谢。另一些人则当场拂袖而去。为了帮助团结各个不同的派别，GBC采取了一个非常简单的立场：大波士顿地区绝对不修建新的高速公路。争论路线的日子已经正式结束。而这个新组织的策略就体现在它的名字里：让这成为整个大波士顿地区的问题，而不仅仅是三个社区的问题。
That's how you get the governor's attention. I had the set of slides in a carousel and a whole group of us spread out over the entire metropolitan area and tell people about the plans for the highway. And everywhere they went, they found people who wanted to listen. Here's Chuck Turner, one of the lead activists in Roxbury speaking at a public meeting. You know, in this country it's a strange thing that if you look on issues, you usually see black people fighting white people, you usually see the rich against the poor, you
这就是引起州长注意的方法。我把一套幻灯片装在旋转盘里，我们的一大群人分散在整个大都市区，向人们讲述这条高速公路的规划。他们走到哪里，都能找到愿意倾听的人。这是罗克斯伯里的一位主要活动人士查克·特纳在一次公共会议上的发言。你知道的，在这个国家，这是一件奇怪的事情，如果你看看各种议题，你通常会看到黑人与白人抗争，你通常会看到富人与穷人抗争，你
usually see the suburbanites against people in the inner city. And it's strange, it's strange when you see one issue. And all those people are united and saying, we don't want to build and we're going to stop it. And Governor Sergeant and no other political official in this state is going to be able to build the highway over that objection. By January of 1969, when Francis Sargent took his oath as governor the GBC protesters were ready. About 2000 folks show up in front of the state house saying what are you gonna do about this road? What are you gonna do about this Sargent? What had started as a small group of Cambridge residents pushing back against a
通常会看到郊区居民与内城居民抗争。这很奇怪，当你看到一个议题时，这就很奇怪了。所有这些人联合起来说，我们不想修建（高速公路），我们要阻止它。萨金特州长以及本州的任何其他政治官员都无法在反对声中修建这条高速公路。到1969年1月，弗朗西斯·萨金特宣誓就任州长时，GBC的抗议者们已经准备好了。大约2000人出现在州议会大厦前，质问你打算怎么处理这条路？你打算怎么处理萨金特？最初只是一小群剑桥居民反对
single road had grown into a radical challenge to the state's entire road building policy. And this was the coming out party for the movement. All the players, all the factions gathered in one place. It spilled down the stairs of the State House over into Boston Common. Fire Department came, people from every neighborhood in Boston. Ansty Benfield led a march over from Cambridge and addressed the crowd.
单条道路的行为，已经演变成对该州整个道路建设计划的激进挑战。这也是这场运动的“出道派对”。所有各方、所有派系聚集在一个地方。人群从州议会大厦的台阶一直蔓延到波士顿公园。消防部门来了，波士顿每个街区的人都来了。安斯蒂·本菲尔德带领游行队伍从剑桥赶来，并向人群发表了讲话。
I want area 15,000. This road is a right road to the middle of it. A group of protesters carried a giant coffin that said, here lies Cambridge, a plain flu overhead, towing a sign that said, homes lies Cambridge, a plain flu overhead towing a sign that said, homes not highways. And so, to his credit, Francis Sargent does come out of the state house on that day and addresses the crowd.
我想要15号地区。这条路是通往它正中心的正确道路。一群抗议者抬着一口巨大的棺材，上面写着“剑桥在此长眠”，一架飞机从头顶飞过，拖着一条横幅，上面写着“我们要家园，不要高速公路”。因此，值得称赞的是，弗朗西斯·萨金特确实在那天走出了州议会大厦，并向人群发表了讲话。
We have with us now the governor, the coming world of Massachusetts. At this moment, Sargent is kind of a contradictory figure. On the one hand, he used to run the Department of Public Works. So he was the guy in charge of planning and building roads for the whole state and acknowledged that fact right away. I was the person who made the decision back a number of years ago regarding the road through Cambridge, I made that decision?
我们现在迎来了州长，马萨诸塞州的未来。此时此刻，萨金特是一个有点矛盾的人物。一方面，他曾经管理公共工程部。所以他是负责整个州道路规划和建设的人，并且立刻承认了这一事实。我是几年前做出通过剑桥修路决定的人，这个决定是我做的？
These people do not look impressed by him, they do not look pleased by him, but he tries to make his appeal. I want you to know. Because on the other hand, Sargent was known as a nature lover and a conservationist. Before he was in charge of roads, he had campaigned to create the Cape Cod National Seasure and protect the whole area from development. So the question was, which side of his past would come out now, the conservationist or the road builder?
这些人看起来对他的印象并不深刻，看起来对他也并不高兴，但他试图进行呼吁。我希望你们知道。因为另一方面，萨金特被称为自然爱好者和自然保护主义者。在主管道路之前，他曾竞选创建科德角国家海岸公园，并保护整个地区免受开发。所以问题是，他过去的哪一面现在会显现出来，是自然保护主义者还是筑路者？
I made it, man, and I said at that time, and I say now, that if we ever build highways, we must build them with a heart. The only concrete promise Sergeant made that day was to review the whole issue of urban highways and come back with a decision. For the protesters, that was not good enough. Work on the expressway was happening. Houses were being taken, land was being cleared, and every day that passed made the whole thing feel that much more inevitable. It's an area place to visit, even on a sunny autumn day. WGBH sent a reporter out to document the empty strip of land that had been cleared for
伙计，这是我做的，我当时这么说，现在也这么说，如果我们修建高速公路，我们必须带着同情心去建造。萨金特那天做出的唯一具体承诺是重新审查城市高速公路的整个问题，并带着决定回来。对抗议者来说，这还不够好。快速路的施工仍在进行。房屋被征收，土地被清理，逝去的每一天都让这一切显得更加不可避免。这是一个适合参观的地方，即使是在阳光明媚的秋日。WGBH派出一名记者去记录那片为
the Southwest Expressway. By the summer of 69, over 1,000 homes had been taken along this corridor, almost two miles long, and there were hundreds more homes still to go. Suddenly, in the middle of the crowded city, there are acres of open space and unnatural quiet. Sometimes, a clothesline and drawing sheets behind a house tells you that not all of the crowded city, there are acres of open space and unnatural quiet. Sometimes a clothesline and drawing sheets behind a house tells you that not all of the buildings in the block are abandoned yet. And far off at the edge of this wasteland, the city abruptly begins again.
西南高速公路而被清理出来的空地。到1969年夏天，这条走廊沿线已有1000多栋房屋被征收，长达近两英里，而且还有数百栋房屋将被拆除。突然之间，在拥挤的城市中间，出现了数英亩的开放空间和不自然的寂静。有时，房子后面晾衣服的绳子和飘动的床单告诉你，并不是这个街区里的所有
To people living in this area, to empty buildings and we build lots have become a nightmare. It's pretty wild. I'll put it a nightmare. It's pretty wild. I'll put it that way. It was it was growing wild. Ronald Perry grew up in a public housing project, less than 50 feet from where the highway was supposed to be built. And as a 13 year old kid, the whole area
建筑都已经被废弃。在这片荒地的边缘远处，城市突然又开始了。对于居住在这个地区的人们来说，空置的建筑和空地已经变成了一场噩梦。这挺疯狂的。我这么说吧。它当时在野蛮生长。罗纳德·佩里在一个公共住宅区长大，距离预定修建高速公路的地方不到50英尺。作为一个13岁的孩子，整个地区
felt like a no man's land. I would like go up to the chain link fence and crawl up and just walk. Would you see other people out there? No, just me and my dog Tiger. That was it. Dirt grass. Just open areas.
感觉就像一片无人区。我会走到铁丝网围栏前，爬上去走一走。你在那儿看到过其他人吗？没有，只有我和我的狗老虎。就这些。泥土、草地。只有开阔的区域。
Just open areas. As he walked along the route of the planned highway, Perry would pass a trailer that the Black Panther party had set up to provide basic health services and breakfast for neighborhood kids. You know, milk, cereal or anything like that. He would then pass the boarded up windows of a local hamburger joint called Kemp's. I don't really remember when it closed just over time, it just gradually disappeared. It was almost like being a bandit slowly but surely. And farther down on the side of a railroad embankment,
只有开阔的区域。当他沿着规划中的高速公路路线行走时，佩里会经过一个拖车，那是黑豹党设立的，旨在为附近的孩子们提供基本的医疗服务和早餐。你知道的，牛奶、麦片或诸如此类的东西。然后他会经过当地一家名为肯普斯（Kemp's）的汉堡店被木板封住的窗户。我真的不记得它是什么时候关门的，只是随着时间推移，它慢慢地消失了。这几乎就像是被慢慢而确定地掠夺。再往前走，在铁路路堤的一侧，
he would see the words, stop I-95. Spray painted in white letters, maybe 12 feet tall. It was huge. It was huge. Even as a kid, Ronald Perry could tell that something big was happening. Neighbors were talking, and flyers were posted, warning of two serpents coming to strangle the neighborhood. That mile of dirt and grass he walked was surrounded by over a thousand units of public housing, a thousand families just like his, wondering how much more land would be taken,
他会看到用白漆喷涂的字样：停止I-95。字母大概有12英尺高。太巨大了。太巨大了。即使还是个孩子，罗纳德·佩里也能看出有大事正在发生。邻居们在交谈，传单张贴出来，警告说有两条“海蛇”来勒索这个街区。他走过的那一英里泥土和草地周围环绕着一千多套公共住房，一千个像他一样的家庭，想知道还会有多少土地被征收，
and what the effects of those roads would be. And so the whole place, the land, the people, the buildings, hung in limbo. What was going to happen to my mother and me, there's a lot of people to this place, and if you just place people, where were they going to go? How come the governor did not stop the demolition of homes that is still going on today? All through 1969, pressure was building on sergeant from all sides. I-95 isn't an answer. It's a continuation. When for some reason it seems fashionable to be against highway.
这些道路会产生什么影响。于是整个地方——土地、人民、建筑——都悬而未决。我和我母亲会怎么样，这里有很多人，如果你把人们安置走，他们要去哪里？为什么州长没有停止至今仍在进行的房屋拆除？整个1969年，萨金特各方受到的压力都在增加。I-95不是答案。这是一个延续。因为不知何故，反对高速公路似乎成了一种时尚。
Because I'm here to stay and don't forget it. Then people have had enough. To the average citizen, it probably didn't look like Sargent was taking any action at all. But that year, the new governor did follow through on his promise. He created a task force to study the issue. And somehow identified me as a person to lead the task force. Alan Allchuler was teaching political science at MIT, and he was content in his academic life until he got the call from one of Sargent's aides.
因为我是留下来的人，别忘了这一点。然后人们受够了。对于普通市民来说，萨金特看起来可能根本没有采取任何行动。但那一年，这位新州长确实兑现了他的承诺。他成立了一个特别工作组来研究这个问题。不知何故，他认定我是领导这个工作组的人。阿兰·阿尔舒勒（Alan Altchuller）当时在麻省理工学院教政治学，他对自己的学术生活很满意，直到他接到萨金特的一位幕僚的电话。
And I said, no. But then Sargent personally called me. He said, he really didn't know what to do about the highways. And I said, I tell you what, this was my fatal mistake. I said, I will do it. If you promise that when we finish, you will publish our report. Sargent agreed, and all Truler got to work. He met with activists from the GBC and heard their arguments,
我说，不。但随后萨金特亲自打电话给我。他说，他真的不知道该如何处理这些高速公路。我说，我告诉你吧，这是我致命的错误。我说，我会做的。如果你答应我们完成时，你会发表我们的报告。萨金特同意了，阿尔舒勒开始工作。他会见了GBC的活动人士并听取了他们的论点，
but what really struck him was the lack of any coherent argument from the other side. The anti-highway people were talking about some of the devastating consequences, and the Department of Public Works really didn't have any significant answers. They just wanted something to build, because building is what they did. Well, they were in tune to be fair to them with highway departments all across the United States. I mean, all 50 states were trying to build
但真正让他震惊的是对方缺乏任何连贯的论点。反高速公路的人士在谈论一些毁灭性的后果，而公共工程部实际上没有任何重大的回应。他们只是想建造些东西，因为建造就是他们的工作。好吧，平心而论，他们与全美各地的公路部门保持着一致。我的意思是，所有50个州都在努力建设
out their interstate systems. This legislation had been enacted in 1956, where now in 1969, no governor or no state government had ever stopped a segment of interstate highway in all these years. So they were typical. They weren't villains of some sort. They were conscientious people who were just doing their thing. In January of 1970, just a few days after New Year's, Alan Altchuller's task force finally presented their findings to the governor.
他们的州际公路系统。这项立法于1956年颁布，现在是1969年，多年来没有任何州长或州政府曾叫停过任何一段州际公路。所以他们是很典型的。他们不是某种恶棍。他们是尽职尽责的人，只是在做他们分内的事。1970年1月，元旦后不久，阿兰·阿尔舒勒的工作组终于向州长提交了他们的调查结果。
It was my job as the chairman to brief sergeant. The report was scathing, not just about the highways, but about the entire planning process that led to those highways, and it basically called on sergeant to halt all construction immediately. His face got red, he stiffened, and he was polite, but I wouldn't have bet at that moment that he was about to take our recommendations very seriously. By this time, a whole year had passed since Sargent became governor, and activists were already planning a second demonstration in front of the state house. Tom Corrigan from Jamaica Plain was leading the GBC and in his words
我的工作作为主席是向萨金特做简报。这份报告是严厉 scathing 的，不仅针对高速公路，还针对导致这些高速公路的整个规划过程，它基本上呼吁萨金特立即停止所有建设。他的脸变红了，身体僵硬了，他很有礼貌，但我当时不会打赌他会非常认真地对待我们的建议。此时，距离萨金特成为州长已经过去整整一年，活动人士已经在州议会大厦前策划第二次示威活动。来自牙买加平原的汤姆·科里گان（Tom Corrigan）领导着GBC，用他的话来说
the goal was to pull out all the stops. The whole of the governor accountable for his lack of action. Then three nights before the date of the protest, a cryptic message arrived from two men close to the governor. They said, call off the demonstration. They were very serious about it. And they came close to saying, we're very close to an announcement. Don't blow it by making him think that he's giving into you by having a demonstration. It was Corrigan's call.
目标是全力以赴。让州长为他的不作为负责。然后在抗议日期的前三个晚上，一条来自接近州长两名男子的隐秘消息送达。他们说，取消示威活动。他们对此非常认真。他们几乎直说，我们非常接近宣布消息了。不要通过让他认为通过举行示威活动是在向你们妥协来搞砸这一切。这是科里گان的决定。
He knew that the rank and foul membership were rearing to go. And the last thing they would want was to give in to the governor's will. But Corrigan decided to give Sargent a little more time. He promised he would resign if the gambit failed. And we postponed it. Did it feel like a gamble though at the time? It's always a gamble, but it worked. A week later, Governor Sargent did something very unusual for any politician.
他知道底层普通成员已经跃跃欲试。他们最不愿意做的事就是向州长的意志妥协。但科里گان决定给萨金特更多时间。他承诺如果这个策略失败，他将辞职。我们推迟了。当时感觉像是一场赌博吗？这总是一场赌博，但它成功了。一周后，萨金特州长做了一件对任何政治家来说都非常不寻常的事。
He said, quote, we were wrong. That day, he ordered a freeze on all active highway construction in Greater Boston. None of the activists I interviewed talked about that day as a major victory in itself. It was only a freeze, pending more study, but at least the destruction of homes had finally stopped. Altchuller remembers going down to Washington, DC with Sargent soon after that announcement and meeting with Sargent's old boss, Volpe, who is now the Secretary of Transportation. They're hoping to use some federal money to further study the state's options and they needed approval from Volpe.
他说，引述：“我们错了。”那天，他下令冻结大波士顿地区所有正在进行的高速公路建设。我采访过的活动人士中，没有人把那一天当作重大胜利本身。这只是等待进一步研究的冻结，但至少房屋的拆除终于停止了。阿尔舒勒记得在那次宣布后不久和萨金特一起去了华盛顿特区，见到了萨金特的旧老板沃尔佩（Volpe），他现在是交通部长。他们希望利用一些联邦资金来进一步研究该州的选择，并且他们需要沃尔佩的批准。
And he went into a ten-minute tirade against Sajin for having made this decision. Sajin just stood there and when it was over, he said, Governor, he still called Volpe Governor. You have to listen to the people. And Volpe twirled around and he pointed at me who he had just met and he said, Frank, you listen and sit at wrong people. Despite that initial response, the Department of Transportation did ultimately grant the funding. That money would support a two-year comprehensive study of the region's entire transportation network, roads, highways, bridges, tunnels, buses, everything. Crucially, Altrule's group looked into whether
他发表了长达十分钟的演讲，痛斥萨金特做出这个决定。萨金特只是站在那里，当演讲结束时，他说，州长先生，他仍然叫沃尔佩州长。你必须倾听人民的意见。沃尔佩转过身来，指着刚刚见过我的我说，弗朗西斯，你听着，坐错了地方。尽管最初有这样的反应，但交通部最终还是发放了资金。这笔资金将支持对该地区整个交通网络（道路、高速公路、桥梁、隧道、公共汽车、一切）进行为期两年的综合研究。至关重要的是，阿尔舒勒的集团研究了他们是否
they could spend the money meant for highways, a new mass transit options, new subway lines, for example. This was unprecedented. No state had ever reallocated money like this. It was a laboratory for what could happen when the narrative changed and the orthodoxy of highways was questioned. At the end of it, Sergeant scheduled a broadcast slot to announce his final decision. Governor's Transportation Message video taken 4 424, air date 1130-72. Did you know what he was going to say? No, we were all lobbying like crazy, but, you know, we didn't know.
可以把原本用于高速公路的资金花在新的公共交通选择上，例如新的地铁线路。这是前所未有的。没有任何一个州以这种方式重新分配过资金。这是一个实验室，展示了当叙事发生改变、高速公路教条受到质疑时会发生什么。在此结束时，萨金特安排了一个广播时段来宣布他的最终决定。州长交通信息视频拍摄于4月24日，播出日期1972年11月30日。你知道他要说什么吗？不，我们都在疯狂地游说，但是，你知道的，我们不知道。
10, 9, 8, 7. So we are all sitting in our houses watching breathless. 8, 7, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, 8, opportunities. The problems of transportation have held us prisoner for forty years, and recently that captivity has become intolerable. You, your family, your neighbors have become caught in a system that's fouled our air, ravaged our cities, choked our economy, and frustrated every single one of us. Shall we build more expressways through cities? Shall we forge new chains to shackle us to the mistakes of the past? No.
10，9，8，7。所以我们都坐在家里屏息以待。交通问题已经囚禁了我们四十年，最近这种囚禁变得让人无法忍受。你、你的家人、你的邻居已经陷入了一个污染了我们的空气、蹂躏了我们的城市、扼杀了我们的经济并且让我们每个人都感到沮丧的系统中。我们还要在城市里修建更多的高速公路吗？我们要锻造新的枷锁来把我们自己束缚在过去的错误上吗？不。
We will not repeat history. We shall learn from it. We will not build the expressways. I think Sergeant's decision to cancel the road was a shock. Better than anything I could have hoped for. So he announced this, and we all, in our individual houses, leaped up and ran to the GBC headquarters,
我们不会重复历史。我们要从中吸取教训。我们不会修建高速公路。我认为萨金特取消这条道路的决定是一个震撼。比我所能希望的还要好。所以他宣布了这一点，然后我们所有人都从各自的家里跳起来，跑到GBC总部，
and drank and cheered and hollabalooed. It was a miracle it seemed. Joy, joy and happiness, and thank the good Lord. With that speech, Sargent removed almost 25 miles of highway from the interstate system. The first time any state or governor had done so. Sargent then went on for almost 15 minutes detailing how the state would seek alternatives to the cancelled highways and invest in mass transit. Yes, highways had been cancelled before, but not like this, not on the scale, not with
喝酒、欢呼、大喊大叫。这似乎是一个奇迹。喜悦、喜悦和幸福，感谢上帝。通过那次演讲，萨金特从州际公路系统中删除了近25英里长的高速公路。这是任何州或州长第一次这样做。萨金特随后进行了近15分钟的详细说明，讲述该州将如何为被取消的高速公路寻求替代方案并投资于公共交通。是的，高速公路以前曾被取消过，但从来没有像这样，没有这种规模，没有
this kind of authority and vision. I think it's worth sitting with Sargent's words for a little longer and reminding ourselves. This is a Republican governor and former commissioner of Public Works, speaking in 1972. The risks we take come down to betting on ourselves. On people versus things, on people versus automobiles, on people versus the reckless destruction of our homes, our environment, the very quality of our lives. All in the false name of progress. The only real progress is the progress of people.
这种权力和远见。我认为值得花更多时间体会萨金特的话并提醒我们自己。这是一位共和党州长兼前公共工程专员，在1972年发表的讲话。我们冒的风险归根结底是对我们自己的押注。是对人与物的押注，对人与汽车的押注，对人与对我们的家园、我们的环境、我们生活质量本身的鲁莽破坏的押注。这一切都以虚假的进步之名。唯一的真正进步是人的进步。
I've counted on your help before, and it's been there. I call upon you once again, and I'm sure that you will answer that call. Every time I hear those words, I feel inspired, awed, really, that our governor could speak with that kind of unabashed idealism, that belief in government, and also with the conviction that it wasn't just talk, it was action. Feels refreshing, to be honest. My interest in this whole story springs from a feeling, a hope, really, that our nation is on the precipice of a new era of infrastructure.
我以前指望过你们的帮助，而帮助一直都在。我再次呼吁你们，我相信你们会响应这一呼唤。每次听到这些话，我都感到受到鼓舞，甚至敬畏，我们的州长竟然能用那种毫不掩饰的理想主义、那种对政府的信仰，以及那种认为这不仅仅是空谈而是行动的信念来发言。老实说，这感觉令人耳目一新。我对这个完整故事的兴趣源于一种感觉，一种真正的希望，即我们的国家正处于新基础设施时代的边缘。
And I'm not just thinking about roads and bridges here. I'm thinking about wind turbines, solar farms, transmission lines, battery plants, about making our buildings more energy efficient, and our coastlines more resilient to storms and flooding. If you look at any optimistic scenario for surviving climate change, it involves building stuff on a totally unprecedented scale. In a way, Sargent had it easy. He was choosing not to build something, to keep things as they were, and I don't think we have that luxury right now.
我这里想的不只是道路和桥梁。我想到的是风力涡轮机、太阳能农场、输电线路、电池工厂，想到的是让我们的建筑更加节能，让我们的海岸线更能抵御风暴和洪水。如果你看看任何关于在气候变化中生存的乐观情景，它都涉及到以前所未有的规模建设东西。从某种意义上说，萨金特很轻松。他选择不建造某些东西，让事情保持原样，我不认为我们现在有这种奢侈。
Which is why the story I'm most interested in is the story of what comes next. It's not about what our state said no to. It's what we said yes to what we did build. Among the many physical legacies of Boston's anti-highway fight, there's now a train line that runs where the Southwest Expressway was supposed to go. This is Roxbury Cross-A. If you get off in Roxbury, those acres of clear land are home to community college, a health center, Boston police headquarters, and the largest mosque in New England. Do you know where to get the back bay, but you want to get on the train towards Oak Grove in two minutes. Imagining a highway here now, it's unthinkable. And out of the edge of the city, you can still see
这就是为什么我最感兴趣的故事是接下来会发生什么的故事。这不是关于我们州对什么说“不”。而是我们对什么说“有”、我们建造了什么。在波士顿反高速公路斗争的众多物理遗产中，现在有一条火车线路沿着原本应该是西南高速公路的地方运行。这就是罗克斯伯里十字区。如果你在罗克斯伯里下车，那些被清理出来的土地现在是社区学院、健康中心、波士顿警察局以及新英格兰最大的清真寺的所在地。你知道去后湾怎么走，但你想在两分钟内搭乘开往橡树格（Oak Grove）的火车。现在在这里想象一条高速公路，那是不可想象的。在城市的边缘，你仍然可以看到
where the two strips of concrete dead end in the woods never to be continued. But there is another legacy, a connection that most people don't talk about and that I certainly didn't understand growing up. Because in that same speech Sergeant gave, there are a few lines about an ambitious and visionary idea. Interesting long term idea, but we'll see. What if the city could go further than just stopping highways? What if it could tear them down, put them underground, and stitch the city back together?
两段混凝土带在树林中成死胡同，再也没有延伸下去。但还有另一项遗产，一个大多数人不谈论的联系，而我在成长过程中肯定没有理解。因为在萨金特发表的那篇演讲中，有几行关于一个雄心勃勃且富有远见的想法。有趣的长远想法，但我们拭目以待。如果这座城市不仅能阻止高速公路，还能走得更远呢？如果它可以拆除它们，把它们埋入地下，把城市重新缝合在一起呢？
This would be better that learning from the past, it would be correcting the past. That actually became the origin of the big dig. And in two years Fred Salvucci would be in a position to take it on. Thank you all for joining us here today for the announcement of a very very important position and it's a decision which required more than a little soul searching on my car. That's next time. The big dig podcast is available wherever you get podcasts. I've heard every episode. I've got a little preview.
这比从过去吸取教训更好，这将是纠正过去。这实际上成了“大开挖”（Big Dig）的起源。两年后，弗雷德·萨尔维奇（Fred Salvucci）将有能力接手它。感谢大家今天来到这里参加一项非常非常重要的职位的宣布，这是一个需要我进行不止一点自我反思的决定。那是下一次。“大开挖”播客在您获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。我听了每一集。我有一个小预告。
It just gets better and better. It is a real triumph. Episode 2 is already available in their feed and new episodes will be released weekly. Go subscribe. The show is produced by Isabel Hibbert and myself, Ian Koss. It's edited by Lacey Roberts. The editorial supervisor is Stephanie Liden with support this episode from Lisa Wardle. May Lay is the project manager and the executive producer is Devon Maverick-Roppens. This episode was informed by two fantastic books about the Boston Anti-Highway movement.
它只会越来越好。这是一个真正的胜利。第2集已经在他们的动态中可用，新集数将每周发布。快去订阅吧。该节目由伊莎贝尔·希伯特（Isabel Hibbert）和我本人伊恩·科斯（Ian Koss）制作。由莱西·罗伯茨（Lacey Roberts）剪辑。编辑监督是斯蒂芬妮·利登（Stephanie Liden），本集得到了丽莎·沃德尔（Lisa Wardle）的支持。梅·莱（May Lay）是项目经理，执行制片人是德文·小牛·罗本斯（Devon Maverick-Roppens）。本集由两本关于波士顿反高速公路运动的精彩书籍提供信息。
People before highways, Boston activists, urban planners, and a new movement for citymaking by Carolyn Crockett and Rights of Way, the politics of transportation in Boston and the U.S. City, which includes an incredibly detailed account written in the 60s and 70s by a Globe reporter named Alan Lupo, a highly recommend them both. To see archival video and learn more about the show, go to gbhnews.org. The artwork is by Matt Welch. Our closing song is ETA by Damon and Naomi. The Big Dig is a production of GBH News and Distributed by PRX.
卡罗琳·克罗克特（Carolyn Crockett）的《人民先于高速公路：波士顿活动人士、城市规划者和造城新运动》（People before highways, Boston activists, urban planners, and a new movement for citymaking），以及《通行权：波士顿和美国城市的交通政治》（Rights of Way, the politics of transportation in Boston and the U.S. City），其中包括由《环球报》记者阿兰·卢波（Alan Lupo）在60和70年代撰写的极其详细的记录，我强烈推荐这两本书。要查看档案视频并了解有关该节目的更多信息，请访问 gbhnews.org。封面艺术由马特·韦尔奇（Matt Welch）创作。我们的闭幕曲是戴蒙和娜奥米（Damon and Naomi）的《ETA》。“大开挖”是GBH News的制作，由PRX发行。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。